listen I have there's times where I want
to like smash Michael or talk about
about him but ultimately have a daughter
and I have to think about her so I
really don't want to you know disparage
Michael in any way in the press or
anything like that even though I want to
but you know Michael I you know there's
good days and bad days I still have
issues and problems but I just don't
like to tell people about them just want
to air I don't want to air it publicly
yes Real Housewives of Orange County
star Kelly Dada keeping things civil
when it comes to her ex Michael Dodd
well for the most part one week he'll be
like nice to me and he'll come over
we'll go have like dinner and then the
next minute he'll see something on the
show they can't like somebody dating and
then he'll go off on me okay but I know
he just goes off on me or like a little
bit and then he he'll turn around and be
nice to me again yeah the pair announced
their divorce about a year ago and is
still figuring out their new dynamic I
mean I've been married to him for 13
years I have a child with him I've built
up assets with him I have had one of the
best times of my life with him he's my
you know he's a great person it's hard
to see your me no matter what it's like
it no matter how you're not in love with
the morning you know you have a kid with
them so it's like is this person gonna
be nice to my child there's all those so
many emotions one thing they have
figured out co-parenting their 12 year
old daughter Jolie you know she always
says mom I'm happy about you and dad are
divorced
she's like a piece she has fun with me
it's like she gets one-on-one time with
each parent it's like we have our
custody is one week on when week off
okay so we have you know we co-parent
very well together No Wow complaints
it's really good so you know and we're
trying to be friendly with each other
and like do things with her so she
doesn't feel uncomfortable or doesn't
feel like insecure because if we were
cool with each other she feels good yeah
and making her the priority right making
her the priority very cool yeah Kelly's
other priority right now
having
fun your relationship status today
single still single it's very single
you have your bench I do who's on the
bench um I have I have a few I'm a few
they don't want me to say they want to
be
don't be private plenty private well my
milkman he calls me all the time still
but we don't we don't have any relations
where's like more like best friends and
then Alex I see from time to time he
calls me all the time once I hang out
the guy at the end yes alex is Alex the
one with the PhD yes yeah that's Alex
yeah oh good old faithful what's on the
checklist for the man you want in your
life I want somebody that I'm best
friends with somebody I'm sexually
attracted to somebody first is like best
friend like fun I could have a good time
with and we can be like laughs like a
buddy right and then second we'll have
be like good sex that's very important
and then third like somebody very very
smart really I want a smart guy and
somebody that you know is driven and
nice there's a why this smart smartest
friend backs and really good sense yes
sound an interview recently you said
you've never had like a romantic partner
that you've considered a best friend
right why is that I feel like maybe my
first husband I was had pressure just to
get married like my parents like kind of
meaning and Michael was like he was just
never my best friend
okay never could just like like he's
socially inept you know what I mean he
always kind of made people like feel
awkward or whatever but he's a great dad
he's a great husband who was always I
just couldn't like go out with him and
like let loose and have a good time got
it and so for whatever reason I've never
had like a best friend I've been
romantically involved in and so that's I
think you know looking back that's what
I want for myself
maybe that's why all my relationships of
like failed third time could be the
charm you want to get married again I
don't know I I say no okay but I mean I
don't know I don't I mean I'm not like
opposed to it but it's also not a must
but it's not a must no I think marriages
for children
okay but I mean if somebody wants to get
married we have a really good
relationship yes
[Music]
[Applause]